e
okay welcome to committee everybody
we're starting a little late but we'll
start with the pledge if everybody would
like to rise and I will ask uh represent
it
okay without any more delay I'll open
sb310 and it looks like all of the
speakers are from fishing
game oh
no okay Eric Anderson uh so we'll start
berson okay then you can open
the I was looking for the senator and he
didn't put a card in so I didn't know
where to go except that I figured that
on oh there it is got it thank
you good morning chairman Spain members
of the committee my name is dy fette and
I the Senate majority caucus director
I'm here to introduce Senate Bill 310 on
behalf of Senator Pearl Senate Bill 310
is a request of the fishing game
department and would give them the
authority to allow bare registration
agents to charge a fee for their
services and to allow digital
confirmation of purchases as a hunter's
current and valid Federal duck stamp
these changes are viewed as housekeeping
measures for the department since be
registration agents are already
authorized to operate under department
rules but the department requires
legislative authority to allow these
agents to charge a fee the change to the
federal duck stamp will bring state laws
into agreement with Federal allowances
Senator Pearl appreciates your
consideration of Senate Bill 310 I will
defer any questions to the members of
fishing game who are behind me as they
will be able to answer your questions
much better than myself I also
understand that there is a non-main
amendment that will be happening after
this and Senator Pearl uh would like to
you nothing anybody got any
questions okay you're out you're lucky
because uh nobody has any questions for
you now I will call uh Dan berson for
department that on
um good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee uh Dan berron I'm the
chief of the wildlife division for the
fish and game department um U yeah I'll
just reiterate very very briefly um this
is largely a housekeeping measure we had
expanded um registration options for
bear um historically bear would have to
be registered by Department conservation
officers or biologists um we wanted to
expand opportunity bear Harvest have
increased over the past several years we
wanted more opportunity for hunters uh
we wanted to set up some regist station
similar we do with deer um currently we
can allow the setup of the stations but
not for them to charge a fee similar to
how deer registration stations charge a
fee for that service um the federal duck
stamp um I think it was about a year ago
um there was actually a bill that was
passed there was a change in the federal
regulations that allowed a temporary um
electronic duck stamp that you could use
for about 45 days until you get your
physical stamp uh Federal Regulations
have recently changed to allow that to
be used throughout the season we're just
bringing up our rules to um or our
statutes to stay in line with what the
Federal Regulations are and I'm happy to
answer any
questions are there any
questions I have one um I'll let you go
first go for it I was going to go last
and I didn't see anybody thank you Mr
chair um thank you for taking my
question just briefly when did the um
fishing gam start doing uh bear
registration stations this last hunting
season was the first season that we had
um stations that people could bring
their Bears to register them to yeah and
I we have a handful that kind of
volunteer to do it without charging
follow up one more if you you may follow
up representative Darby uh thank you Mr
chair um and has there been any um my
understanding was the reason um fishing
game uh conservation officers were uh
directly involved was before was to
maybe look at the the site where the
bear was taken uh make you know a lot of
bear hunters use bait and things like
that was there has there been any any
concern by fish game about um lack of uh
information lack of sort of Trace back
to where the bear was taken no so we
discussed that prior to changing over
but they still have the ability to go
check those sites if necessary um you
know it varies you know typically
because there was you know a handful you
know we have 40 some odd and I defer to
um our our Colonel behind me um 40 some
officers throughout the state
registering hundreds of bears throughout
the season so um there could be quite a
lag so typically when they would go to
register a bear it wouldn't be at the
kill site so they'd have to get the
information from the Hunter and go back
anyway um and they still have the
ability to get that information from the
Hunter and and have them take them back
to the site of kill
yep question go ahead thank you Mr
chairman forgive me if I missed this but
the procedure now um to uh to register a
kill is what so there 's several options
right now for bear um we we do have a
handful of registration stations that
you can bring your bear to um they're
just not able to charge a fee for the
service so we had some stations that
volunteered to do it for us free of
charge um you can also still contact a
conservation officer and do it the way
that that historically um Hunters have
been able to register and you can um you
know Regional biological staff can also
register a bear for a hunter so there's
there's now three options um biological
staff conservation officer or or bring
it to uh one of the select registration
stations
y any further
questions mine's been answered so we're
good um with that um no further
you and the last one I see is Eric
Anderson was that actually for this bill
or for the non- gerine amendment
310 it's for the amendment oh okay then
we'll hold off on that because that one
was not being heard right now is there
anybody else who'd like to speak on the
ground the the basic Bill 310 not the
non- gerain amendment that goes on
it seeing none we'll close the hearing
sp310
e we'll open the uh public hearing on
Amendment
2024-25 n h to Senate Bill 310 and call
on represent a
Spain thank you Mr chair members of the
committee this amendment was a request
from the Department um it was basically
something that came out of the hearing
we had earlier on Landing licenses um
and they had realized that they did not
have a resident non-commercial version
and that in order to create this license
they needed to have permission for the
director to create such a license so
they asked me to put in an amendment uh
that would allow the director to create
such a license and so that's all this
does it uh allows any non or actually
it's
uh
non-resident
right yeah non-resident sorry
non-resident for personal use uh so it
allows a non-resident uh transporting in
state waters any crabs or lobsters that
were taken outside the jurisdiction of
the State uh via ship or vessel so in
other words this would affect people who
have a moing in New Hampshire but
they're lobstering in Massachusetts or
in international waters and they're
doing it just for their own personal use
so they've got a non-commercial license
in Massachusetts they're just doing
their Hobby lobstering and they want to
bring their lobsters to shore where
their boats mored in New Hampshire
and right now um they'd have to buy a
full license here so this gives the
director the ability to create that
license um and put a price on it and
legally deal with it and so if there's
any questions I can take them but I'd
probably defer to the department to
answer them better
uh representative Derby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
representative Spain just um out of
curiosity you're own personal opinion um
I've we heard in previous testimony over
Landing licenses that some of um some
states do not offer reciprocity what's
your opinion on reciprocity um you know
reciprocity requirement or um
reciprocity um state reciprocity for
allowing um personal uh take and landing
of licenses by our neighbors well it's a
good question but I can tell you that
there's a lot of our hunting and fishing
uh Licensing in in areas that does not
have reciprocity and I can give you a
good example of that um quite a number
of years ago uh I put in a bill that
would extend the discount for veterans
that are disabled to be able to have a
hunting
license and uh we had only one category
which was 100% fully disabled could get
a free hunting license in New Hampshire
and we had reciprocity with Vermont and
Maine for that but in order for us to
create this next tier which was 85%
disabled up to 99% disabled for a
discount on their lifetime hunting
license uh we had to remove the
Reciprocity for that category so um we
were not going to be giving that to
Hunters in Maine and Vermont either just
New Hampshire residents they were
veterans so there's a lot of those areas
where we do not have reciprocity and
it's not a it's not a problem it's a
common thing uh and in those instances
people just buy the license in the state
activity any other
questions Mr thanks for taking my
question turn on your mic
um so a local resident who's not fishing
in New Hampshire Waters but fishing in
federal waters wants to land their
Lobster in New Hampshire are they now
required to buy the commercial we have
$40 we do that okay have
yeah I want to make sure they didn't
have to buy the commercial LIC no no no
we just didn't have one for non-resident
to to do that for their personal use
and honestly in talking with fishing
game maybe a handful of people might do
this it's not a a big number because uh
again you'd have to be landing your boat
in New Hampshire but you're an outof
State person so it's it's pretty much
limited to those people who happen to
have a moing or or a friend who has a
moing and they're coming to visit their
friend or what have you and they're
bringing their lobsters or crabs or what
have you from the other
state and they're perfectly 100%
licensed in the other state for the
activity
too any other
good morning thank you very much um for
testifying on this um my concern with
this amendment
is probably for informational purposes
I've consistently supported fishing game
in the variety of you know legislation
that comes before you and and still
support that but I think for
informational purposes there are issues
that I I have questions about and um you
know it seems to be that we're catering
this this particular amendment is
catering to non-residents with regards
to your question about reciprocity I did
check that out um there is not like for
likee reciprocity between Massachusetts
and New Hampshire on this a individual
from m Massachusetts can come up here
and purchase a license non non-com well
if this goes forward purchase a
non-commercial personal um a
non-commercial license and the fees yet
to be established and that's all he has
to do if there was a New Hampshire
resident that wanted to go to
Massachusetts and get a similar
license he can do it but and that's the
butt he has to own $5,000 worth of
property in
Massachusetts I think that's relatively
clear it's not like for like
reciprocity
um so I think for I I just wanted to
bring that forward for for informational
purposes because it was we because it
was
discussed um also in
Massachusetts um they're allowed to take
Lobsters by
diving which is not allowed in State of
New
Hampshire now I don't know the fiscal
impact or you know what the what the
size of you know the type of licenses
this will um produce but it it
there's with the fact that they can
come that they can die for lobsters in
Massachusetts and bring them to New
Hampshire where it's not legal it seems
like a non-resident
has more entitlement to the harvesting
of lobsters than a New Hampshire
resident because it's not allowed in New
Hampshire
um and I I think that's a factor in just
my you know I think it could be easily
fixed if the was language in there I I
see it on line 19 if they could just say
um after and crabs in the state if they
could say by means of trap and that
would make the issue equal between the
two states rather than have um an
individual go Bringing In lobsters from
Massachusetts that they caught by diving
so
um I support the Department's position
on this I think the front end of the
bill on 310 is the most important part
um I just ask you know I'm just bringing
this information to you for your
consideration on whether adding the the
amendment is appropriate thank you very
much thank you any
[Music]
Brown I'm s go ahead sorry uh thank you
Mr chair so to be clear uh my
recollection is that this license for
New Hampshire would only
be for those fishing outside of New
Hampshire's jurisdiction lobstering
outside of New Hampshire's jurisdiction
yes what you're saying is in
Massachusetts they
may get a lobster inside Massachusetts
jurisdiction and bring it to New
Hampshire and that's your
concern yes and it's it's it's it's not
that that's the main concern it's the
means of
harvesting diving full Ops is legal in
New H in Massachusetts it's not legal in
New Hampshire so it seems to be that a
Massachusetts resident can Harvest
Lobsters by diving in Massachusetts
state waters and this would allow them
to bring those lobsters into New
Hampshire with this non-commercial
license okay where a New Hampshire
resident couldn't do the same okay thank
you follow up Mr chair follow up
so again to be clear if if anyone
corrects me if I'm wrong you can collect
lobsters outside of New Hampshire Waters
off of the New Hampshire Coastline by
diving if you're outside of New
Hampshire jurisdictional Waters right
and you're outside of New Hampshire
you're technically in federal waters but
you you can you can do that at this
point whether it's federal waters or
state and Massachusetts Waters you're
allowed to you're allowed to harvest
that thank you yep not in not New
Hampshire state waters thank you
appreciate
that any other questions
saying none thank you thank
Michael Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm Captain Mike Le from fish
and game department I'm here just toh
speak about uh this amendment and uh to
the Lobster Landing uh statute and uh so
the Marine Division and uh law
enforcement worked on this bill and uh
we would agree that it it's certainly uh
it's certainly enforceable and that the
commission uh Fishing Game Commission
does uh promote this bill and approve of
it so um that's really what I'm here for
any questions that anybody may have
about uh Lobster
Landing any questions representa Derby
thank you Mr chair uh thank you Captain
for taking my question
um I'm wondering um sorry I'm wondering
if what the rules are in in Maine for um
Landing
lobsters I can't speak specifically for
Maine I what I can tell you is that
Maine is has very stringent uh Lobster
uh landing and um and and just
lobstering laws period um due to the
fact that um generally it's it's just a
resident residential or resident um take
of lobsters um they even have laws that
extend out into federal waters which we
do not have in this state um so if a
main resident or a holder of a license
um would be um could be or main laws
could be enforced in federal waters for
those persons holding a a lobster
license in
main one more follow thank you Mr chair
um thank you again um how would um with
respect to enforceability um how would
you be how would the um Department um
conservation officers be able to
determine if a lobster caught by a
non-resident was caught in New Hampshire
Waters versus outside of New Hampshire
them it would be difficult at the I mean
at the initial contact to where it was
landed I mean certainly cases like that
developed over time um if it's someone
that's legally taking within state
waters or in federal waters and landing
in the state of New Hampshire It
generally takes a little more than just
that initial contct so it's more of
investigative uh they would be you know
finding that person taking lobsters you
know out in the field and developing
information that way and and creating
doubt any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
uh that's the last pink card anyone else
amendment seeing
none I'll close the public hearing on
okay we're going to open S SP
544 and I recognize uh daily fette for
I have
am
okay hello again Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is dy fette and
I am the Senate majority caucus director
I'm here to introduce Senate Bill 544 on
behalf of Senator Pearl Senate Bill 544
is a housekeeping bill as well as a
request of the fishing game department
in the past Hunters have had to
transport deer to a physical station for
registration and issuance of deer seals
HB 1230 in 2022 mandated the
establishment of an online registration
system by fishing game which resulted in
the electronic issuance of confirmation
numbers to Hunters SB 544 aims to update
statute where placing references to the
outdated deer seal to align with the
modern electronic registration system
thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to speak today uh once again
I know there's a lot of fishing game
department people behind me I think
they'll be able to answer any questions
that you guys may have
thank you so much for your testimony I
won't even ask for
questions you're uh you're all set and
berson right after him I want to do the
amendment at the
end good morning again um Dan bergon
chief of the wildlife division for
fishing game um yeah this is this is
very much so a housekeeping bill um with
the change to electronic registration
stations um obviously when when
someone's doing it online there's no
ability to give them um you know metal
SEALS or anything so they print out a
confirmation number or they can save
their confirmation number um so as
opposed to having multiple forms of ways
that we have to track these things
that's a lot of administrative work for
the Department um we've switched over to
now confirmation numbers this is just
updating the language and there's
various rsas throughout um that
referenced the deer season that would
reference seals um to the old way we
used to do things we're just looking to
update it for the new the new
system thank you are there any
questions seeing none you're all set
thank you very much chair will now
recognize representative goalie who has
an amendment to this bill that he'd like
committee yes
sir we will he just wants to explain it
in the general It Won't Be Moved
now thank you Mr chair and um uh as a
co-sponsor I'm here and support of
Senate Bill
544 um I was contacted by uh fishing
game uh to some technical changes that
just needed to be put into the bill
that's before you um which was forwarded
to me and I had drafted as an amendment
um they had also spoke to Senator Pearl
who's in full support of the changes as
well so I just wanted to uh make that
offering and if there's any questions on
this amendment and that why the changes
were needed I defer to the department as
to the changes thank
you he's deferring to the department but
we will have them next which is why we
wanted to have this discussed now God
thanks um who would like to come up and
speak on behalf of the department on the
questions for the amendment
required we didn't have a paper version
of that right I don't think we got a
copy of that it's getting passed around
thank you
again representative Derby you're
question thank you Mr chair um actually
I did have a a tech a question regarding
the original bill that I forgot to
ask on line
25 um it talks about provide a
registration
number but in um both sections one and
two of the bills it says a registration
confirmation
number and so um I'm wondering if those
are intended to be the same
thing and if um since the uh the the
terminology seems to be registration
confirmation number and we have a an
T um yeah I don't I don't think we would
have a problem with that to put just put
confirmation in there make it consistent
throughout that would be fine with
us the and just real quick to speak to
the the amendment this was this was
originally included in the in the bill
that we um asked to have sponsored it
was accidentally left out by OS and we
didn't catch it until um after it had
been introduced in the Senate so um but
again it's it's all the same subject
matter thank you and and I think I'll
I'll point out
uh on line 13 it does say the
registration confirmation number and on
line 11 it says registration
confirmation number y in the original
Bill yes it's line 25 which is what I
was talking about yeah it just says
registration number but not confirmation
got you okay we could actually send
someone down to have the word
confirmation added into the amendment uh
before we hear that in exec session so
that wouldn't be a problem if we want to
get the language all nice and clean
thank you for bringing that
up uh are there any other questions
while we've got the fishing game as
answering uh
questions no all right thank you thank
you and I have no more pink cards is
there anybody who wants to speak on this
that hasn't spoken
yet okay seeing none we will close the
10:45 and we have time for a break so if
to it is
25 it just says registration number not
registration confirmation number it says
else
e
r
all
right all right it being uh past 10:45
I'm going to open the hearing on Senate
Bill
503 and I recognize Senator
Waters thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee Senator David Waters
District 4 to introduce uh Senate Bill
503 relative requiring criminal back
ground check when applying for fishing
game guide
license um the the key to this bill uh
is on line 7 where it says every new
applicant applying for uh New Hampshire
guides license for the first time shall
submit to the fishing game department of
criminal history record release form um
and also a set of uh
fingerprints um what is what how the way
we amended the bill in the Senate was to
ensure that it's first time got got app
so that we're not um adding costs uh to
this um process or having people repeat
it who have been through it once um the
necessity for the um fingerprinting is
so that we can obtain criminal records
from jurisdictions Beyond the state of
New Hampshire uh I think the basic uh
purpose of the bill is to supplement
what we already have to make sure that
um people who use guide services are
safe um this is a very important
relationship guide we'll have with folks
uh in their in their guiding and um the
public is the right to know that we've
done our due um diligence uh so I think
that uh what made this bill workers in
the Senate is to make sure that it's for
first time first time applicants only
that were uh re requesting this there's
a small technical change in the bill as
well uh about on the early lines about
the
design um there as you'll see on uh line
three the executive director or to their
designate just a grammatical cleanup on
on that one um I know we've got folks
here from the Department to um talk more
about the practicalities and the reason
for bringing this forward but uh if you
want to ask me questions I can answer
but you'll probably get better answers
from them thank you are there any
questions representative Derby thank you
Mr chair thank you Senator waters for
taking my question and just to confirm
this would apply to all guides fishing
and hunting guides anybody who has a has
a a guide license okay thank you thank
you any further
questions I have one myself you may
defer to the fishing game department if
you do not know the answer was my
understanding because I thought we
already did this for guides it was my
understanding that we can do this for
any Resident who applies for a guide
license but we could not mandate that
somebody from out of state who applies
go through the background check and this
would just bring us on par so that
residents are treat Tre the same or
non-residents are treated the same as we
treat our residents is that not correct
thank you Mr chairman and they can
further discuss that but that's the
point of the fingerprints so that we can
get somebody's from another jurisdiction
we can get that that safety uh as well
thank
you thank
you I have I'm in the middle of
executing I will be back at at 11:10
thank you thank
you if you want to ask him a question
you can ask him in the hallway and if
you want to ask or do any kind of
testimony I'd ask you to fill out a pink
you and I will now call Representative I
mean Colonel Jordan sorry from the fish
and game department I got to put my
glasses back on before I read these
things there we go is my sincere hope
the representative never precedes my
name frankly God bless you I'll take
that in the manner it was intended yeah
well it was a compliment I don't know
how or why quite frankly that you do
this but thank goodness that you do it
before we start I want to thank you for
all the work this year uh with all of
the different bills I appreciate the the
hospitality we receive over here on a
regular basis so I am Kevin Jordan I'm
the chief of law enforcement for a New
Hampshire fishing game and I'm here to
testify in support of Senate Bill 503
the commission voted on this bill and
voted to support it once we explained um
the purpose behind it and so just to
give you a little background any any
fishing or hunting guide now resident or
non-resident we run their criminal
backgrounds but by state law we're only
allowed to do that within the state of
New Hampshire so if I get a
Massachusetts resident who applies for a
non-resident guides license I can check
his criminal background in New Hampshire
but I cannot go out of the state and
check other states and I can't check a
resident uh in another a resident from
New Hampshire for another state so I
could be a New Hampshire Hunter I could
commit a felony in Vermont reapply for
my guides license and there would be no
way that I would be able to um see if
that occurred without this bill so
initially we wanted it done we wanted to
require every applicant to submit
fingerprints pay the 48 to 50
$48.50 fee to have a complete criminal
background from across the country uh
done the problem with that is it
increased the guides licenses by some
$50 which was a the guides we worked
with the guides Association which by the
way supports this bill as well couldn't
be here today but asked me to tell you
that um that was their only concern was
the headache of getting fingerprints
each year or each time they got their
license and paying this additional fee
so we kind of compromised on this
onetime check my feeling is and it's and
it's my opinion frankly that once we get
them in the system once I we know who
they are and they are guiding here in
New Hampshire that if they were to an
offense a felony offense outside of the
State of New Hampshire we'd be more
likely to know that than I would before
they became a guide so we agreed to do
it in that fashion um and then the last
thing I want to remind you of is before
this committee and I think Senator
Waters was on the committee I know uh
the chairman was on it we did have a
felon uh who was taking out Children uh
in Bob houses and offending them he was
a convicted felon before he got his gu's
license we did not know that we issued
him a license and he used that as a tool
so I'm fearful of that um I want to make
sure that people take folks out in the
woods that they're uh good people and
they haven't done those kinds of things
and this is the only way I can I can be
sure of that thank you thank you any
questions I'll have one yes sir this is
sort of a followup and continuation of
what we did earlier uh several years ago
to pass the uh legislation that said
that a person with a
criminal sexual record couldn't take uh
couldn't Mentor people that's correct in
the woods correct that's correct yes sir
okay any other questions seeing none
thank you colel thank you sir thank you
Colonel always a pleasure you
too and I don't have any more pink cards
is there anyone wishing to speak on the
bill that has not yet
503 your amendment's small on that right
so we'll do that in exact
session and your
15 we're going to take another little
break because uh we're 15 minutes early
and I believe Senator Waters is our next
one as well and he's in an exec session
in the Senate so
um we'll be on recess
until
11:10
e
is might as well use this as an
educational moment for the committee uh
this happens a lot in fishing game uh OS
likes to put an effective date starting
60 days on a lot of our stuff by default
and frequently we have to wait because
it has to be going through a lot of
legislative
uh stuff to get it instituted with rul
making and everything so we can't do
everything within 60 days so we have to
delete it and if you do draft a bill for
this committee try to always start on
January 1st it's always safe that way
it's uh it's much harder to now amend it
so
e
I might as well say that too it it's
been a pleasure having you all in the
committee this this uh term and uh I
look forward to seeing you on the
committee again next term however we may
fall out after elections but uh I think
we've had a great term here it's been
for the most part non-c contentious and
uh we've gotten some good things done
and and we've ended up the the the term
without fishing game hating us so that's
a reminder to people too we've got the
guns on the 15th at 8:30 a.m. over at
the Sig place um which is in
eping uh we've got uh some members from
fishing game that the colonel still
hasn't told me their names or anything
we got four or
so have four I think I gave you four
yeah and then uh we've got some
Commissioners
coming not not sure how many
Commissioners are actually coming
because I don't think I've heard from
all of them but I did hear from about
five or six that can't make it so
I think I think I might have heard from
three or four that are they're coming
and and I've heard from about four or
five I think that can't make
it um but then I've I think I've heard
from most of the committee members and
if you haven't responded yet please
do and Mike would you like to talk about
we've got a few minutes for you to talk
about the four-wheeler trip
too thank you um we're in the process of
putting a a day together um a big part
of fishing game and how they deal with
the citizens of New Hampshire through
their law enforcement of the motorized
Motorsports and we don't see a lot of it
don't hear a lot of it in committee so
I've worked with a rental uh
organization up north to supply side by
sides to any of the fishing game
committee members come up for a day uh
tourists up through the area hopefully
through Jericho Park includes some of
our fishing game members and Bureau
trails and just get a feel of what the
great Northwoods is like
um the only uh we have to pick a date uh
the only uh caveat is it's got to be
midweek um but um the rental house is
prepared we'll have the local club or
someone Supply lunches for us and uh you
know a nice three or four hour tour
through the uh through the North
Country so we've got the date still TBD
but Mike's going to come up with
something real soon and uh I asked him
to do it after we finish our last
session day so we don't have to worry
about that um and and Colonel Jordan do
you know who's going to be up in Patrol
in that area and who covers that area'll
there
okay I'm getting a feeling Scott Wallace
might show up
[Laughter]
too
absolutely
e
all right it being time I'm going to the
chair will now open the hearing on SB
542 and I will recognize representative
ulette to open or introduce the bill for
Senator
Waters good morning and thank you uh to
be brief this is uh a bill to establish
a committee to study fishing game
department funding and Partnerships um
we uh uh ask and demand fishing game to
do more things where they've been
self-funded in the past um and as a
legislature we wanted and we did give
our uh employees raises last year and
they're having a hard time funding them
out of their budget so it's time to look
at other funding Avenues and um the best
way to to help keep them afloat and this
is going to establish a committee to do
that thank
you I'm not going to entertain questions
since he's just introducing it for
Senator Waters but when Senator Waters
shows up he can fill a card out and
we'll fit him
in chair now recognizes Kyle Baker
Federation uh good morning Mr chair
members of the committee thank you for
um having me here today uh my name is
Kyle Baker I work for young pingelly Law
Firm here on behalf of the New Hampshire
Wildlife Federation New Hampshire
Wildlife Federation is a nonprofit made
up of about 50 different sporting clubs
from around the state um with an
Affiliated membership of about 50,000
Sportsmen um and women um and we strive
to be the New Hampshire's um oldest and
strongest nonprofit advocating for the
right to hunt fish and trap in New
Hampshire um we don't have take a
position on the underlying Bill we just
they just asked me to flag um lines 24
through 27
on page one um deals with 206 2A of
qualifications for the fishing Game
Commission um and as you all know
earlier this year this committee um sent
house bow 1148 to interim study which
also dealt with uh the fishing gameing
at the fishing Game Commission so we
just wanted to flag it as far as um if
we're going to have an interim study uh
committee already meeting this summer
maybe um this commission doesn't need to
directly act on it so um that's the only
thing I wanted to flag um reading
through the bill but happy to take any
other questions that folks might have
thank you
appreciate that any
questions seeing none thank you very
much chair now recognizes um William
Bosworth representing himself and the
Coalition thank you Mr chairman I'm
Welden Bosworth from Guilford and as you
said are representing the New Hampshire
wildlife
Coalition um first of all I find myself
on the same side as the fishing game and
in supporting this
bill uh but I have to ask the question
why do we re revisit this issue every
few years in 2007 the legislative audit
committee did a great audit of fishing
game and came up with 30 recommendations
that related to funding and
organization very few if any were
actually implemented and in 2018 Senate
Bill 48 the hearings of which I sat
through eight of them uh were who were
charged to look at the operations of uh
fishing game basically Sid stepped the
issue of the organization and and focus
primarily on funding which was great but
at the end of the G end of the day only
one of their recommendations even got to
legislation and that died in committee
or was ited at least
so I guess I'm hoping that this one will
get a little bit
further one of the things that uh
I I guess I have a problem with is
representation of people like
organizations such as ours which are
Wildlife advocacy organization are not
represented on the commission and it's
my belief that if we had a broader
commission more organizations
represented sugested at the original
bill with Senator Waters Native
Americans conservation agent uh
organizations and so forth that maybe
there'd be some uh support for some of
these funding ideas at least a little
more support presently there's only
40,000 people in the state 40,000
residents that actually buy a hunting
license or a combo license hunting and
fishing about 3% of New Hampshire's
population so you have a commission that
largely represents those people there's
a heck of a lot of other people that
have a very high interest in wildlife in
fact studies that have been done show
that the people who are so-called
Wildlife Watchers who watch Wildlife up
close who photograph it who feed it
outnumber Sportsmen by 3 to one and they
spend more money as
well the present uh RSA 2062 and 2A
really establishes a couple of
requirements that make it very tough for
an organiz organization like a wildlife
advocacy organization to get on they
require that that organization having
its bylaws that they promote
hunting and while many organizations
like ours do not oppose it I think it's
absurb to think that a organization that
a conservation organization is going to
promote hunting the other thing that
makes an exclusionary is the requirement
to hold a hunting license or a trapping
or fishing license for five of the prior
years so not everybody in the state that
loves Wildlife is going to have a uh a
license to kill them so I I I'm just
saying that we have to make this a
little more
Equitable wildlife in New Hampshire are
a public trust resource and as such
they're held in trust for all citizens
all 1.4 million not just the 30,000 buy
a hunting license and the 70,000 that
buy a fishing license so it's
my wish that if this committee gets
together that they spend a lot of time
on the
organization and perhaps by doing
something about it the funding issues
would be
solved thank you very much for your time
I'd take any questions thank you very
much sorry for getting your name wrong
Weldon you put W and I couldn't quite
remember it that's right anybody have
any questions you are recognized
thank you Mr chair uh thanks for taking
my
question you didn't say this
specifically but are you suggesting that
Wildlife Watchers would then be somehow
licensed in some way to contribute to
fishing games
management of of game fish and game uh
what I'm suggesting is the commission
which is right now uh restricted to
those people that are nominated by
sporting clubs and typically are are uh
basically enthusiastic supporters of the
hunting and trapping community be
broadened by having commission members
who come from different walks of life
but still have an interest in Wildlife I
I understand that thank you did you have
no okay any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony y chair now
recognizes Colonel Jordan
oh actually Senator Waters you can come
in now I forgot I didn't have your card
in front of me we introduced it for you
and you're all set to go ahead and speak
to
it uh thank you Mr chairman Senator
Waters District 4 and my again my deep
apologies to you Mr chair and the
committee we got tangled up in votes and
I didn't look at my watch so here I am
and I appreciate the uh bill being
introduced in my my absence and if I um
let me just start at the beginning with
this uh I as you know the underlying
bill um was a different thing to look at
the uh commission and um some other
folks related to it and we ended up
having a very long conversation in the
hearing about issues surrounding the
funding of the department going forward
and um so that's why it resulted that
working with Colonel Jordan and with the
director and with others that we asked
for this study committee to look at the
funding issues if I may I will look
think back to 16 years ago when I my
first term when I was here on this
committee and we had just received um
the audit of the department and we
really spent the next um four years
under chairman Abbott and CH chairman
Hopper um looking at the all kinds of
things fishing game and um a few years
later arising from the continuing
funding concerns we did the hike safe
pass and for the first time uh added
some general funding for fish and game
and so I think those conversations made
us all aware of the of the fact of the
challenges uh here given the mix of
resources coming into the fishing game
um Department um I think what's become
rather apparent since that time uh are
the continuing challenges in particular
you know thank you thank you to governor
sonunu for funding the raises in this
budget for fish and
game but that funding will run out and
the department will be expected to pick
that up that might mean layoffs of what
eight or nine people in the in the
department so that's going to be
immediate challenge for the budget
writers next time but in the longer term
um it seemed to me that we really needed
to really look very honestly at what are
the funding needs going to be going
forward and what are what is the role
going to be of other funding sources and
perhaps the general fund so in looking
at the in the bill I thought about a
couple things you know yes we got to get
a good handle on what projections are
about um about revenues and so forth um
and I will say you know looking back to
what we did about the hike safe pass
that the concerns about the search and
rescue funding which can sometimes be
quite enormous have not gone away uh
made some some progress on it with the
hik safe pass but you know a couple of
extensive and dangerous searches and
rescues and we can be in real budgetary
problems there it also seemed to me
though um that we have a lot of work
that if you look at what the fish and
game department does I mean it it is you
know under sight evaluation committee
for uh Power projects Dees hands off to
fishing game a lot of the examination of
what impacts there might be there and
and you know across all kinds of
development issues and so forth um
fishing game is you know asked to to
play its role in determining um
environmental impacts of all kinds of
construction projects um then also a a
lot of its work overlaps very much with
what are land land conservancies and of
course with outdoor recreation um that's
now a multi-billion dollar industry in
the state and uh really it depends a lot
on the work of fishing game department
to make sure that those lands are
available for people who want to
recreate as well as hunt and and fish so
um that's why I have down here um not
just you know under line 18 18 and 19
consider proposal for General funding
needs sustaining programs operations not
provided by federal funding but also
might not we look on lines 20 to 23 um
at these other groups you know
agriculture we had in the hearing too a
lot of talk with um you know Agriculture
and Timber interest because it happened
at the the Farm Bureau and the
Timberland Association folks were there
that that day as well and I followed up
with them too um you know they all we're
all doing the same kind of thing making
sure that we have uh lands available so
I thought that you know maybe there'd be
some Partnerships with those uh groups
and that they might be able to bring
some f some funding from their
membership towards fishing game as well
now that's why I had on lines 24 to 27
well if we're going to if they're going
to be funding Partners maybe they ought
to have some role consultancy with the
commission I kind of think it might make
sense cuz what I've heard since time is
that maybe just strike lines 24 to 27 I
don't think they're they're necessary in
terms of this study maybe that is
something that will evolve later on as a
consideration but I think this study is
really about funding and potential uh
partnership so I I I think that um you
might strike 24
to um 27 and then uh might want to look
at 20633 about um enhancing funding
partnership
um and in those kinds of areas so I'm
sorry to take a little bit time Mr
chairman but um you know given my ever
since I'm in the legislature my
commitment to fishing game and the great
job the department does you know Colonel
Jordan just everybody's the best and I
think it's our responsibility to to make
sure that they have the funding they
need thank you thank you Senator are
there any questions for Senator
Waters seeing none thank you much for
your time I'll let you get back to your
votes again my apologies and I will Dash
Jordan everything all right I heard
something snap so good morning again
Kevin Jordan the chief of law
enforcement New Hampshire fishing game I
don't think I could have said it much
better than Senator Waters did um you
know with the the uh search and rescue
funding crisis we I came over here for
some 16 18 years asking for more more
adequate funding and and we could prove
and did prove through statistics that
the sports men and women were paying the
Lion Share of that and yet they were
receiving probably 3 to 4% of the
services and so that argument would we
went round and round over all kinds of
different ways to fund that through
rooms and meals and general uh General
um funding um and we settled on a hike
safe card which really to be honest with
you wasn't I wasn't a fan of in the
beginning and it does create a bit of a
problem when you budget because you're
budgeting for what you hope will come in
which is a little bit of a challenge but
the good news is since
2015 we've exceeded $200,000 every year
this year we're going to hit 300,000 so
it's been a huge help to have some of
that money come in from the people that
are actually receiving the services so
that's that's been a great um Advantage
it kind of planted the seed for this so
when Senator Waters came up with a bill
this year to look at the commission and
I went in screaming that our big problem
isn't our commission our big problem
isn't representation our big problem is
paying for it moving forward and it's
getting worse and worse every year
because the the cost of everything
including salaries you know the governor
was gracious enough to give the
employees a 10% raise I didn't we didn't
increase uh income by 10% so we're not
going to make it and and I'm worried I'm
going to lose my Governor I'm about to
lose my director um and so there's no
good on the horizon for that so and
we've had bills like this we've had
Senate Bill 48 which I know some of you
are familiar with where we've studied
the funding of of the commission but let
me tell you how those work i' I've seen
this happen and I don't want it to
happen this time what typically happens
is people good people will get together
and come up with ideas on how to better
fund the agency like they're small ideas
a lot of them they are things like um
we've tried adding registration costs to
boats we've tried registering kayaks
we've tried um you know a whole host or
gamut of ideas not that those are bad
ideas but those are not going to take
care of our issues we need millions of
dollars not
hundreds what I would like to see happen
with this come up with an idea or a
willingness to general fund the agency
like every other agency is in the state
of New Hampshire mostly and then give me
the ideas to go out and reduce that cost
then I'll listen to the ideas of maybe
increasing this cost maybe doing
something different over here some of
the some of the more Band-Aid cost of
that but give the initial funding so the
pressure is off us we can continue to do
the good work that we do and then we'll
come up with ways to reduce that each
year I'm all about that I I would be
100% in favor what scares me is these
little ideas that end up a lot of times
costing us more money for administrative
cost to implement than we get from the
actual funding I'm not saying they're
bad I'm saying they're not enough I'd
like to see it go the other way this
time as far as representation on the
commission I'm going to tell you
something a personal feeling about
representation everybody in the state of
New Hampshire including everybody in
this room benefits from the work that
fishing game does without question if
you like seeing animals if you like a
healthy turkey population a healthy
moose population or coming back a the
best deer population we've had in the
history since I've lived here that comes
from the hard work of the people s
sitting behind me not me but Dan and his
team um and the management and and and
determinedness of uh determination of
the officers in the field to make sure
that these rules are followed everybody
benefits from that everybody benefits
from it but there's a small percentage
paying for it I'd welcome anybody to the
table just come with your checkbook I
want to see you pay just like the
hunters and the fisherman do that I
don't think that's unreasonable and I
think going to the general fund is an
opportunity to do that now if you do
that I've said to my
commission there's going to have to be a
discussion about who is on that
commission I think in time but I think
it's premature to do it now because
their funding is not it's coming in but
it's at a greatly reduced amount
compared to what the sportsmen and women
are doing um I think bringing everybody
on board for funding this agency is a
great idea and then we can talk about
who's going to represent it I think then
that is a more sensible argument but the
idea of coming in and having input
without your check is not a good idea
that's not helpful that's not going to
solve our problem I don't need
information I need money that's what we
need to run this agency the last thing I
want to leave you with is we do you know
there was a time when I first started in
fishing game where you actually could do
law enforcement you could check hunters
and fishermen and that was your day now
we steal time to do that I literally
steal time to do that because we're
doing rabies calls we're doing nuisance
animal calls we're doing search and
rescue it's becoming more and more
involved every day that's okay we're
doing that I've got a staff of really
energetic people thank goodness um much
younger than me that that work hard
every day and I'm willing to do that but
a lot of that is unfunded a lot of it is
unfunded and the Sportsman's dollars are
paying for the fuel the insurance the
salaries of these people it's time for
everybody to step up and the only way to
do that is two two funding mechanisms
that I'm can think of is General General
funds or rooms and meals um and I know
they're both hard cells I understand
that but losing this agency is is going
to be worse I think and and we're
getting closer to that each year we
really are that's that's all I have sir
thank you thank you Colonel are there
colonel Vice chair goalie and then
Darby thank you Mr chair and thank you
Colonel Jordan for taking my question um
being the chair of the Senate Bill 48
study committee um I saw some of the
things that happened there and um some
of the Quest and one of the things that
was put into that report was dealing
with the hearings
process putting it with fishing game so
you could collect the dollars for each
one of
those hearings that took place and the
monies instead of going to um was it
State Police that was doing I forget who
was doing for court summonses yes yes
fines yes yes yes
um and that
was five years ago that that report was
written yes and that hasn't been done
yet correct no sir no we haven't changed
the legislation to allow for that that
is that was one of the one of the ideas
that came out of that study committee
and it's also one that we have talked
about internally for quite some time and
that is to bring funding from our fines
directly back into the agency and cut
out the contributions to police
standards and training the courts um I
that would be met probably with some
opposition from some of these other
groups certainly but it would help fund
the agency yes that was one of the ideas
that came out of
that and one other follow follow go
ahead I mean we also had the
recommendation
of kayaks and canoes permitting for boat
launches because we
knew 50% plus of launches are for car
top only carriers and these folks are
paying nothing towards that right we
tried that as well and I think people
here know the number of canoes and
kayaks in this state that use launches
is substantial I think that could have
raised not just nickels and dimes right
would have raised a substantial amount
we tried that here in that legislature
and went it ended up going through to
just a voluntary and it it's unfortunate
and my question is you know you bring up
the point of doing these reports and
hoping something comes out of it well we
did that report we had some good things
with do you think that there's going to
be a real solution that comes out of
this that will pass this house and get
put into statute to fund fishing game
because I think we had a lot of good
ideas in that last report that didn't
get done I I think you do if you go
after one thing I think in the past
we've gone after 50 different things I
think if we go after General funds
period nothing else General funds fund
the agency then come up with the idea
ideas like you're discussing and we'll
reduce that general fund input each year
I think it's a better way to go we've
never done it that way we've always gone
after rooms and meals or general fund
and then it splinters off into that I
think concentrate on getting the funding
because that's what's needed now that
requires all these other ideas would
require legislation some follow-up work
to be done I think get the general funds
get the agency funded period then go
back with some of the ideas and see if
we can reduce that cost each year I
think we can I think there's some good
ideas out there but we need the funding
that's the problem and what typically
happens is we Splinter off into these
little these other little ideas some of
them happen some of them don't um and
our problem lingers on and we're just at
a point where we can't linger anymore
we're running out of time so let's get
the funding from a single Source now um
and and you know you can also make the
argument if it comes out of General
funds then the people with a kak and the
canoes are paying because it's coming
out of General funds everybody's paying
which is really the only fair way I
think to do that everybody benefits not
just the kayakers everybody benefits
from it thank you representative Derby
you still have a question you're
recognized thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question yes good
questions by the way well thank you very
much sir um I'm just curious how many
conservation officers uh fishing game uh
currently has and how many how many
billets or how many what's the maximum
they could have so so right now the
governor gave us four other well I kind
of split it with him he gave us four
unfunded positions back so I agreed to
pay for two of those out of OHV money
because we are finally at a point where
we can support that and he gave me two
additional ones so we are in the process
right now of hiring four more I will
have 48 that will be the highest number
of conservation officers we've had since
the 70s I could use 148 but 48 is better
than where we've been so we're not
having trouble recruiting we're we're
getting reduced numbers when people
apply but we still are are having very
good luck uh finding quality people we
just hired two more women very excited
about that they're both they both come
with uh experience and they're both very
energetic and we hired three young men
that just finished the academy uh two
weeks ago so we're we're gaining ground
in that regard excellent thank you yes
thank you thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you thank
and I don't have any more cards was
there anybody who did not get a chance
to speak who wants to
speak seeing none I will close the
hearing on which one was this
we've got about seven minutes you can
caucus before the
uh for the executive session if you'd
like and uh I believe the Democrats are
going out with uh chairman Vice chairman
goalie into the Hall uh if the
Republicans wanted to step into my off
office we could do it there out of the
public
it
e
seeing that our time is here for exe
session I'm going to open the executive
session on four bills which is SB 310
542 and I will start by looking for a
motion on uh 310
310 I'll make a motion not to
pass okay uh representative Brown has
made a motion to I have a second
representative Darby's a
second we have the bill ought to pass
it's open for
Amendment uh we do have a non-gain
amendment that you all had the public
hearing on and we're going to offer that
one up I'm going to offer that one up
since it's in my name for s
sp310 that is amendment number I can't
remember the number so I have to look
for it hold
on it is
16598 and this was again the one that
was requested by the department so that
the director can uh create a
non-resident priv uh personal
non-commercial Landing
license
um I'm going to move OTP on the this
second representative Tudor
seconds I'll now speak to it uh very
briefly you all heard the discussion on
it there was one thing that I did he
that I wanted to uh respond to which is
uh
any any implication that uh we should
care in New Hampshire what the legal
methods of take are in any other state
is off bounds for us we don't police in
New Hampshire how the hunting rules are
set up or the fishing rules are set up
in other states if they can legally die
for lobsters in Massachusetts and they
follow the law in Massachusetts and they
bring those they they do that and
they're licensed we're just saying they
can land them in New Hampshire it
doesn't make any difference um we do the
same thing with hunting laws that vary
from from uh state to state sometimes a
method of take is not the same in one
state as another we still allow someone
to bring the the animal back to New
Hampshire and so I don't think it's I
don't think it's something we need to
concern ourselves with as long as they
follow the laws in that state and the
animals are legally
gotten then we should be able to have a
landing license for them and that's
where I'll leave my comments on and why
I support
it is there any okay uh representative
Derby thank you Mr chair so I I support
this amendment as well um I do hope that
um our neighboring state realize that
we're offering um a benefit to their
residents um and they may reciprocate
with similar um uh out ofate um
non-commercial Landing licenses because
there are people that land in Northern
Massachusetts or or launch their boats
out of Northern Massachusetts Waters
where this would benefit them but I
support this because I think that New
Hampshire can be you know can set the
standard here I appreciate that cuz I
agree with you I think that they should
be reciprocal to us any further comment
Ms on this
amendment all right not seeing any I'll
allow the uh clerk to call the rooll and
if there's not too much we can just do
it by a show of hands unless people are
going to disagree and it'll make it go a
lot faster does anybody have a problem
with show of hands let's do show of
hands everybody on in
favor it's unanimous save you some work
Mr
clerk okay so now we need a motion on
otpa I don't think we need a separate
motion for that right that's just we do
okay so you want to make your you want
to amend your motion to an o otpa or
make one or do you want to make the
motion this time I'm I'm happy to make
the motion chair okay we we'll switch
the order on that Darby motions
otpa Brown seconds I'll second that
that's okay I don't mind wri in and can
we do this one by a show of hands as
well no
rooll hang on there it
is sh don't do this
enough uh representative
goalie yes
representative kofalt yes representative
tutor yes clerk votes
yes representative nter yes excuse me
and I missed representative
Murphy
yes representative
wette yes representative abar yes
representative D
Fox
yes representative Fox L Fox
yes representative Vu
yes representative Paige yes
representative PE yes representative
Darby yes and the chair
yes did you I in for smith I did vote
who did I miss Smith W yeah yep
representative Wallace
that gives me 17 yes Z no
consent all right with no objection
we'll go to consent with
that I will now entertain a motion on SB
544 oh that's the uh closed hearing on
sp310 let's open exec on 544 FN and I'll
entertain a
from
anybody I move out to
pass all right representative Brown
moves out to pass do we have a second on
that representative pair I'm going to
oh the one that we just got from down
there all right let's do the the real
quick one I'm going to offer Amendment
uh 1806 H which fixes the problem that
we found in committee by putting
confirmation in front of number in the
language and that's all I need to say
about it is there anybody else who has
anything to say about it or discuss it
seeing none can we I'll second that you
need a second oh thank
you all right so it's been moved and
seconded there's nothing else to go with
on this uh no discussion so let's go
ahead with a show of hands on the
amendment and that's unanimous and now I
amendments thank you Mr shair I'd like
H and I'll second that
and I'll just speak briefly this was um
the amendment that was just clarified
some language that fishing game had
requested um by the time it had gone
through the Senate and they caught the
uh error it was uh too late to have
redrafted it had been voted on so they
asked that we put that in here and
Senator Pro was in full agreement so I
had asked the committee to um adopt it
any further discussion on that
Amendment not seeing any let's go with a
amendment
unanimous we can now entertain a motion
of otpa if somebody wants to make it
because I don't see any further
amendments
pending so moved moved by rep Page
seconded by rep peir I saw your
hand
uh representative
goalie yes representative Wallace
yes representative kofalt yes
representative Tudor yes clerk votes yes
representative Murphy yes representative
naer yes representative
wette yes representative abar yes
yes representative El Fox yes
representative AO yes representative
Paige yes representative PE yes
representative Derby yes and the chair
I have 16 not 17 we must have had extra
on the other one okay check the other
one okay
160 1 2 3 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
544 exec session sorry exec s onb 544
here at the front that's what I thought
I thought that's why I opened it for all
at the
right yes if possible so anybody have an
consent not oh fiscal note
can't that's right
all right regular calendar because of
the fiscal note thank you for that
reminder U Mr chair
yeah imp is l1000 I
think substantial yeah so it's not
substantial so and if they if they can't
then they'll he won't let it go on but
it's the less than
10,000 so let's go with consent and if
not if they don't like it they can pull
yep all right I will open the exec
s503 and I'm going to look for a
motion
anybody come on don't be
shy I'll move out to pass representative
Paige moves out to pass representative
do we have an amendment on that one no
that one has no Amendment so that's a
simple
one is there any discussion you made the
motion do you have anything to say about
it we've already heard so all right then
role representative goalie
representative goalie yes representative
Wallace yes representative kofalt yes
representative tutor yes clerk votes yes
representative Murphy yes representative
na yes representative wette yes
representative AB Bear yes
representative D Fox yes representative
L Fox yes representative Au yes
representative Paige yes representative
peir yes representative Darby yes and
the chair yes I only had 13 no kidding
Z I'm going to object to consent on this
floor if anybody's curious I'm putting
my brass knuckles bill on it on the
floor because we passed it through the
house twice and it got killed on the
other side of the wall and I'm going to
so close the exec on 503 even though I
don't need to and open the ex next
session on
542 I'll look for a
motion representative Derby yeah Mo OTP
yes thank you chair I make a motion OTP
on Senate Bill 542 second it's been
moved and it's been seconded it is now
open for further Amendment and I know
that the vice chair has an amendment to
offer thank you Mr chair I've passed
around to everybody uh Amendment I'd
if I can get a second I'll speak to it
seconded by the clerk pass it
around anybody need a copy I thought it
for us you were just waiting for people
to find it I didn't know you were
waiting for your second has every has
okay and if I may Mr chair um all this
amendment does is we heard Senator
Waters testify to uh
striking those striking lines 24 through
27 um BEC regarding the makeup of the
commission um and I had this amendment
drafted for that reason uh those of us
on the committee know that we have a
bill that we intrum studied uh that
deals with the makeup of the commission
that will be looked at in another way
and I just don't think it's right to
have two separate entities look at the
same issue at the same time I think it's
more it's a just as important to have a
separate bill looking at a commission
looking at the funding efficient game we
had heard how important that is and
letting a different group this committee
deal with the commission part of it and
the inim study so I uh did what the
senator had asked for and put the
amendment in and that's all that does
one second because I wanted to look at
something here on this
Bill yes okay section three got it any
further discussion on it anybody have
any other concerns none not seeing any
uh we'll do a show a hands for the
amendment uh all those in
favor
unanimous it's open to further Amendment
but we have none that's all I was
checking for was to see if we had a
second amendment on that um and although
I'm in favor of the second amendment I
don't have one for that um all right so
we can have the clerk call the
role oh no we need a motion does anybody
have a motion for us now representative
Darby thank you Mr CH I'll make the
motion ought to pass as amended on
Senate Bill 542 and I'll second that
thank
you and now we can have the clerk call
the rooll because I don't see anybody
wanting to
speak okay
representative
goalie yes representative Wallace yes
representative kofalt yes representative
Tudor yes clerk votes yes representative
Murphy yes representative n yes
representative wette yes representative
abar yes representative D Fox yes
representative L Fox yes representative
Vu yes representative Paige yes excuse
me representative perer
yes representative Derby yes and the
chair yes
it that's the last of our bills that's
the end of the exact session thank you
coming good question I need the reports
uh technically by the end of the day
today um but if you want to get them to
me tomorrow morning that's fine as
well I'm supposed to say before you
leave here today but you guys me on
Tuesday yeah
get right we got a little bit of time
but if I don't get something by you by
from you by tomorrow morning I'll be